under the rain under the mercy of the
elements these are the latest victims of
the ongoing violence in Kaduna State
hundreds of them have been come to this
school since March this year when gunmen
from an opposing tribe attacked their
village killing dozens and destroying
homes our main problem the moment is
shelter from then we were able to go
back home they will talk about security
located in northwestern Nigeria and with
a population of nearly 6 million Kaduna
State has been embroiled in conflict for
decades the violence has its roots in
ethnic tensions between the state's
Muslim and Christian populations the
Muslim Christian divide has been so
exacerbated by the fighting that the
government has mandated these two men a
Muslim Imam and a Christian cleric to
use the pulpit to try and bridge the gap
between their two communities and they
have brought together traditional
leaders to join their course the
politicians have taken this important
element sensitivity to our religious
values as a chess game for winning
political office this is why it becomes
so same as the James Weir is himself a
victim of the ongoing conflict he lost
his arm when his village was targeted in
the tit-for-tat attacks and now wears a
prosthetic arm I wish they know the
benefit of peace sometimes I feel
incapacitated I wish I am this Superman
somewhere in a movie that can go drop
waters in trouble zones I say stop this
killing it will not help you the
conflict is mainly concentrated in guro
Kaduna but has also spilled into the
city the people of Kaduna have also been
physically divided along religious lines
with River Kaduna forming a natural
boundary many Christians have fled the
state over the years fleeing the almost
endless cycle of violence those that
remain behind have sought refuge in the
south and part of the city while the
Muslims dominate the north this man the
governor of Kaduna is also leading
efforts to bring peace to his conflicted
state we are making progress Rome they
said it was not built in a day
we are very realistic about expectations
we are pragmatic about this but what we
are optimistic about is that we are now
as a state as communist state were
moving in the right direction in the
first six months of this year ethnic
clashes in northern and central Metiria
have killed an estimated 1,300 people
that is six times the number of deaths
from the war with Boko Haram according
to the International Crisis Group
it's these grim statistics that make
them need to bring peace to the affected
areas ever more urgent mohamed al
jazeera Kaduna nigeria